hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting game from round three of the
2018 Sinquefield Cup it's again between
Hikaru Nakamura and Alexander Lee shook
before we check out the game we do have
a nice challenge best of luck to
everyone who is the young gentleman in
the photo here
there you have it now let's check out
the game before we check out the game we
can also check out this very nice photo
of Jeanne and Rex Sinquefield presenting
Maximo Cheryl agree with this very nice
check you know just to get in the mood
now let's see what happened here Anna
come on had the white pieces and he
opened with e4 we have e5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 Bishop to c4 the ship to c5
so does aqua piano game and here b4 the
Evans gambit was not played by nakamura
in this position unfortunately I rather
he went for d3 the joko pianissimo
Knight to f6
we have castles castles and c3 d5 pawn
captures Knight captures we have rook to
e1 and Bishop to g4 now pinning the
knight Knight B D - we have nice to b6
and now Bishop to b5 this was a played
plenty of times by many many many strong
players before Bishop to d6 and here h3
Bishop to h5 Knight to e4 and now rook
to e8 also possible I guess will is f5
and it's a very very interesting what do
you do here for example Bishop to g5
attacking the Queen Queen d7 and now you
have to do something with the night and
Knight captures Queen captures and it
seems like a very nice position for
black and the engine doesn't mind this
position but for some reason rook to e8
is the standard move in this position
okay Bishop to g5 attacking the Queen
now f6 another one of those positions
where it's actually okay to push f6
Bishop to e3 and now a6
White has to decide what to do with the
bishop Bishop captures on c6 b captures
on c6 and now comes Knight the g3
attacking the bishop you don't want to
grab blacks the dark square bishop and
illuminate here's bishop pair because
you would simply improve his own pawn
structure and create create this massive
pawn chain in
so after B captors on c6 nights the g3
attacking Goethe shoots
bishop on h5 we'll have Bishop to f7 and
here we have the exact same position
Carlson had against eleven our engine in
your next move the Louvin blitz
tournament in 2016
here at Carlson proceeded with d4 and
then nice the c-4 was plays pawn
captured the sub casters and so on and
so on but here instead of d4 Nakamura
goes for c4 and the engine actually
prefers knock Morris moves slightly so
our one could say that Nakamura has
prepared for this position okay Bishop
to b4 as c5 was a threat now we have
rook tree to end now Bishop to f8 b3 now
comes c5 and now Queen to e1 so if you
look at this position for a bit you can
see that agree she has this c5 pawn and
this e 5 1 so he really does have firm
grip on the d4 square on the other hand
Nakamura has somewhat of a grip on the
d5 square but not as firm as bishops for
a grab on the d4 square because even if
this night somehow gets for example D to
B 1 C 3 and B 5 this you can always
remove it with c6 and you know usually
the plan is and when you want to attack
a weak backwards pawn such as the d3
pawn you first want to block 8 it create
an attack against it and then at some
point to a point win it but here it's
not all that important to block it at
the pawn as there is no way this one
will ever be able to be pushed forward
so let's see how Grisha Kerr approaches
this position a5 okay we have rook to d1
now comes a for a knight's the d2 we
have Queen to d7 and now Knight the b1
pawn captures pawn captures and Bishop
to g6 now again creating an attack
against the weak backwards form f3
hoping to create an out poster for this
nice the blockade the bishop on g6
rook a to d8 again piling up against the
d3 pawn queen to f2 and a now comes
Queen to c6
defending the c5 pawn we have looked at
and now comes the night study 7:00 at
some point a glitch will push f5 and he
wants to bring this night over to f6 we
have a nice to see three we have h6 and
now King - h1 King - h8 night the b5 now
Bishop to h7 and now rook to a to f5
Legree shook we have a push up to c1 and
now comes knight Knight to f6 as planned
Knights the c3 Queen - b7 attacking the
b3 pawn and look to be - and here g5 you
might think okay one at f4 this attacks
the night also creates a very nice
double attack against the d3 point well
it's because this knight cannot simply
go to e4 blockaded this Bishop and black
doesn't really have that much advantage
now so I have to look to be to first g5
by Grichuk look to be one now as group
does have a king Ganesh it Nakamura
wants to bring this bishop over to be -
to put put it on a very nice diagonal
Queen to c6 we have good shop to be -
and now King back to g8 I'm getting it
out of this diagonal Knights to f1 and
we have a nice to h5 again f4 would be a
bit premature as now this knife can
block it with Knight to e4 so ok after
night if one knife to h5 now having a
very nice grip on the f4 square as well
and also keeping pressure on the g3
square nights the d5 and here comes
Queen to d6 the thing we discussed a bit
earlier in the game even if this night
ever King comes to d5 very simple plays
Queen to d6 and will now kick away this
night with c6 so agree she didn't really
need to stop a Nakamura's plan of
bringing this night over to d5 sometimes
you just have to see what your
opponent's plan is and allow him to
execute it because it's not a very good
plan it's okay Knight to g3 we have C 6
now Knight goes back and now Knight to
f4 again piling up on the d3 pawn and
now you see that which have simply kept
improving the position slightly over
time he allowed this knife to come to d5
pushed it back now he played Knight to
f4 and now there is no way to defend the
III pawn queen qf1 was played and now
simply night captors and III grabbing
this pawn that was kind of the point of
this whole game night c2e2 now we have
Queen to e6 now unpinning Bishop to c3
and now rub the d6 preparing to double
up on the D file
rook to d2 Nakamura also prepares to
double up on the D file rookie 38 and
now rugby to d2 to d1 better up to g6
taking away the h5 square from the night
Knights the c1 and now Knight captures
rook captures and d6
Bishop captures and now rook captures on
c1 rook to b8 and now rook to a1 you
can't really defend it with rook here
not because of this f4 move you can
again block it here with the 9th but
rather efore now creating an attack
against the night here and after you
move the knight here comes f4 I have two
it captures here comes Bishop captures
and now you really have no other moves
you're rupees under attack after you
move it you get Queen captures on h3 and
what simply falls apart here so after
rook to b8 we have root 2 a1 and now
rook captures on b3 rotate check rogue
blocks
rook back to a six and now Bishop to f8
so now the Queen will be guarding the c6
pawn queen to e2 and now comes Bishop to
g7 our group takes it slow as of course
I haven't seen the game but most likely
as usual he as he is known to be a ton
trouble addict he was most likely in
time trouble so perhaps he didn't have
have time to calculate e4 as it again
works F captures only for F for
attacking the knight Knight goes back
and now rook to B 3 will give black the
decisive advantage but okay
Oh Queen e2 Bishop to g7 was played rook
to e7 and now rook to e8 h for pawn
captures on h4 92 f1 and now F for
Knights - D - we have rook to e7 rook
captures Queen captures and the Knight
to e4 Bishop to f7 pressuring the c4
pawn we have King to h2 and now comes h3
a very nice move by Trisha because now
King capture some h3
will be met with queen 2e6 check and you
moved the king and now you grab the c4
pawn queen captures Bishop captures and
with three extra points and the bishop
repair this will be a decisive advantage
for black so after h3g captors on h3 was
played but now simply Queen to e6
I wouldn't attack against the c4 pawn
king queen to g2 and now King - h7 not
going for Queen captures on c4 and
allowing ideas such as Bishop captures
on e5 it seems that the black is not
able to prevent checkmate here but of
course that would not be the case black
has this quaint way to move that pins
the Queen and now after Knight f6 check
King moves captures captures King g2
still of course black has is up two
points but it's a CC pawn so perhaps
white could still produce some tricks so
okay Queen g2 King to h7 Queen to c2 now
pinning creating some ideas like Knight
f6 chick and Queen h7 checkmate so after
King to a trade we have Queen - B - now
King moves back we have Queen back to c2
angry shook Nakamura would very much
enjoy a draw a repetition here Queen to
g6 now Queen to e2 and now Bishop to e6
preparing Bishop to a5 Queen to f1
Bishop to f5 and now Queen to e2 Queen
to h5 here if you go for the immediate
but should capture screen capture screen
captures and F captures is you would
most likely still be able to win this
body you know you don't want to allow
any any for any accidental fortresses
there are a lot of light squares here
all of your phones are on dark squares
it's not all that clear how your King
would be able to enter the game stove
after Queen e2
Queen to h5 Knight 2 f2 and now comes
Queen to h4 a very nice move threatening
Quinta g3 and there is really nothing to
do here anymore if you try something
like Queen to f1 the guarded the h3 pawn
then you get twin G to recheck King
moves captures King moves and now you
lose the bishop on c3 and it's all over
so after Queen to h4 you get Knight to
e4
the g3 square but now it's Queen
captures on h3 King g1 and Queen to h5
we have Bush of to e1 butter captures on
e4 Queen captures on e4 and now Queen to
g6 with a check blocking the check and
creating a check of his own and now the
Queen's are getting traded off king h2
Queen captures F captors and King to g6
now so here the Greek is up three points
and it's and the same bit of color in
game so it is very much winning King to
h3 King to h5 who have Bishop to h4 and
now f3 excellent move by Trisha because
now King the g3 will be met with simply
f2 threatening the Queen
you would have to capture you would lose
a piece and of course the game so after
this f3 move Bishop to f2 was played and
now Bishop to f6 Bishop do you want now
Bishop to g5 and we're back to f2 white
doesn't really have all that much to do
here again if you try King g3 Bishop
checks you lose the bishop so after
Bishop g5 Bishop to f2 we have no show
back to e7 and now Bishop to e1 here
agree she took a couple of moves to
decide how to break through butter up to
d8 Bishop to g3 again attacking d5 pawn
and here agree she found that kink the G
file heal out
Nakamura to capture d5 pawn Bishop
captures and now Bishop to f6 offering a
trade of course the black or white
cannot allow this trade as the opponent
game is winning so King to d6 now we
have F 2 again a very nice move kingi -
and now Bishop to deform defending the
f2 pawn and also the c5 pawn king to f1
now comes King g4 King me too
now comes h5 as now agree shook is ready
to push his outer passed pawn king get
one h4 Bishop to h2 h3
kingi to here agree she played Bishop to
e3 and it was in this position and move
89 that Hikaru Nakamura decided to
resign the game
what if you resign if you are perhaps
new to chess you're welcome to pause the
video and figure out what is the winning
plan here so you know I will give it a
second if you want to you
just to do it so for those of you who
were able to do it how congratulations
you are an excellent end game player and
for those of you just wanna enjoy the
show well first of all you have to play
something if you play something like
King f1 simply repeat then Bishop to f4
is coming
attacking your Bishop here you don't
have the option of moving it as the G 1
square is guarded after version capture
screen captures you will capture here
and after King captors while you're busy
stopping the the past H pawn you this
King will capture the C pawn and then
you will push your own seep on to
victory and if instead you push a 5 for
example then King f5 preventing the
point from being pushed forward a king
f1 you can simply block the pawn here
and now after King repeats now you play
this you attack the pawn after Bishop g3
you will simply capture here you don't
have the option of capturing with the
bishop because then h2 is coming you can
stop the pawn on a light square so you'd
have to capture with the King and again
we have the same idea captures captures
and then now while the king is busy
stopping the pest h1 you will grab this
pawn and after this you will simply
create a wall here and you will push
your pawns to victory so that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it after Bishop e3
movie d9 Nakamura resigned and a very
nice game for guru who after round three
I joined the leaders of the tournament
here we even have the standings so let's
check it out there you have it in first
place to live on onion
Magnus Carlsen soccer mom Jarvan
alexander Greece took all of them with
two points as the three of them drew
their games in round 3 and Greece should
wonder who won his game then we have
good 1 and 1/2 point machine-washable a
Gruffalo karana in Vishwanathan Anand
now with one point he Colonel Nakamura
and Wesley so and in last place who
after two losses came strong with a draw
Sergey Karjakin so now once again I do
hope you enjoyed it and that you're
enjoying the coverage of the single cup
so far I would like to thank his villa
Ruiz for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here I think all for watching and
I will see you soon hopefully would
another interesting video and yes for
all of you wondering I am still
preparing the official arson series but
I am
really busy these last few days so
should be should be very soon I think
you'll and I will see you soon